- On this episode
Krewella stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 215
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
And this is a fun show I got a
whole crew with me and I'm in
the VaynerMedia LA office as we
normally drill this
in New York City.
I'm thrilled to be here.
I'm excited about this episode
I think we actually have similar
backgrounds in to how we got to
this moment so actually
let's start with that.
Vayner Nation, why don't you
guys introduce yourself to
everybody. Why don't you
tell them who you
are and what you do?
- I'm Jahan.
- I'm Yasmine.
- We are Krewella.
- This is our manager,
Jake, one of our managers.
- Hi.
- For everybody who's
watching, what is Krewella?
What do you guys do?
Where'd you guys come from?
What kind of music genre,
like, how do you guys roll?
- We're from Chicago.
Gotta get that in first.
- I graduated
with Jake, this guy.
- Is that true?
- Yes.
- We're all from Chicago.
- Hold on. Hold on.
I did a little bit
of homework beforehand.
Did you grow up,
are you from Chicago or
from a suburb of Chicago?
- We're from a suburb of
Chicago but we like rep
the city because we
definitely did live there.
- On a side note this is
amazingly weird timing,
I'm obsessed right now
with Chicago hiphop.
- Good.
- Oh great.
- Yes,--
- Like Nissa?
- Yes but more so Chance The
Rapper and even I'm obsessed
with Saba. I think Chicago is,
which by the way, this is a
weird thing to say I don't get
beat up right now on my show
I'm historically pretty
disrespectful to Chicago
just as an FYI.
I want to be authentic.
- Why is that?
- Maybe because it's a
little New York bias and
I'm disrespectful it every
city besides New York.
I don't know.
I'm weird about Chicago it
makes me sad to say that because
Brandon Warnke who runs Wine
Library, my best friend in the
world, is a huge Cubs fan so
I have a lot of love for that.
I don't know.
It's always windy, I don't know.
- But it gives you thick skin.
If you're walking to work
everyday, walking to school and
you have this
brutally cold frozen--
- I respect that.
- blowing at your face when
you do that every day
you can handle anything.
- There is some truth to that.
Why don't you tell everybody
a little bit about your music?
'Cause I think it's really cool
and I think we'll go
into the questions.
No India today so
we've got a substitute.
I think you're going
to do a great job.
I'm very confident.
(laughter)
You guys want to go a
little bit more into it?
- We are electronic
dance music artists.
We're singer,
songwriters and DJs.
We are currently working on
our second follow-up EP to
"Ammunition" which we just
released a month ago.
Going on the Sweat Box Tour in
fall which is in tiny venues,
like sweaty punk rock venues and
we're bringing our whole rocking
rave style there.
That's with currently
happening for us right now.
- And so when I was doing a
little bit of, there's a lot of
fans at Vayner of
your guys' work.
There were some people are
pretty excited in New York that
were sad to find out this
show was being filmed here.
For the music enthusiasts
out there I kinda asked this
off-camera before we started
which I hate doing which is why
I'm bringing it up in what
kind of popped for you?
How did you guys hit the scene?
I think one of the things I'm
most fascinated by and knowing
there's a lot of entrepreneurs
and business people and
marketers here I do think the
internet is the true middleman.
I was curious about, I asked
you, when was your pop moment?
When did you guys pop and
you kind of laughed and
I laughed because
everybody sees the results and
you're like it's kinda a long
journey and my answer
was, "Well, of course."
And I know most
people don't think that.
It's always years
and years of work.
What were those moments?
What were the sites
or the blogs
or the moments within that
ecosystem that kind of first
made it happen for you guys?
- You actually mentioned 'This
Song is Sick" before we went on
air and they were one of the
first blogs who posted us--
- Is that right?
- we freaked out
when they posted us.
- Because you were
fans of it already?
- Oh yeah.
We trolled their blog like crazy
for new music and to be posted
on there was such a
huge deal for us.
Then we belonged
in that community.
- You love hearing that.
- I do because I,
I love being transparent.
A couple months ago I bought a
very large stake
in "This Song is Sick".
- Amazing.
- Something VaynerMedia did
for your publishing decision.
I just love those guys I
just gave you some of the most
authentic stuff in
indie pop mediums.
Very cool. That's cool to hear.
What about online video?
I've seen you guys put out
several videos, they look really
cool you guys should watch them.
How did those go for you guys?
How is that
experience in general?
- I think that really
gained attention for us
was the "Killin' It" video.
It was the first time people saw
the face for the artist and
I think that identifying was
really important for our fan and
seeing what is beyond just the
song that they're listening to.
And at that time there weren't
artists in the electronic dance
music scene where the vocalists
were actually in the group.
A lot of the time the
vocalist was a mystery.
- That's right.
- So you go to these festivals
and download these songs and it
would be just the name of
the DJ or producer and there
technically it was a ghost
singer you wouldn't know who the
singer is or the vocalist or the
writer of the song is so we were
one of the first groups at the
time who had a producer in the
group who was Chris who is
in the group with us and then
Yasmin and I being the vocalist
singers and songwriters of the
group as well.
- And what about
from your perspective?
From your vantage point
what have you seen what's been
interesting in their rise
or in the marketplace today?
- I just think they offer
something completely different
to the space.
There was no women whatsoever
at any of these dance music
festivals and Jahan and
Yasmine had this real desire to
understand the scene.
They wanted to come at it from
an authentic yet very different
way and that worked.
And it always works online.
- When it's real.
- Yeah. When it's real.
- Alright let's get
into these questions.
- Hey what's up
Krewella and GaryVee?
My name is Steven Gold.
There's so many good producers
out there right now getting
released on labels, getting
uploads on Sheepy and Proximity
all these channels.
Getting blog coverage, even
charting on Hype Machine.
What separates the artist that
get all this promotion and just
get a little bit of royalties
here and the artist that
actually get to make
a living off of music?
- Anyone who isn't afraid
to experiment and I always
appreciate producers when I hear
them who step outside a certain
BPM or even genre.
I always love risk-taking
mentality and for me
those are the people that I'll
remember for years and years and
just to name a few like
Skrillex, we're big fans of
Skrillex, of course. Everything
that Jack Q does is really cool.
Panpour Nerds we're huge
fans of them. And who else?
I would say Discord love
what they do as far
as experimentation.
- I also think that musicians
who are able to create a song in
our EDM world is amazing because
you get so used to the build up,
then the drop then the break
down and the build, the drop and
it just seemed so contrived
after a while but you get people
like Calvin Harris who make real
songs that embody so much more
than just the build and the drop
and I think that is incredible.
- I think my answers going to be
slightly more in the context of
how you guys know that I roll
which is I think what separates
is the market decides.
This whole notion that there's
so much great music I think
there probably is and I think
some of the great music of all
time was never heard because the
market decided it wasn't great.
Meaning who gets to
decide what is great?
And I always find
that super fascinating.
It is an executive who's got
an ear like is a Clive Davis
through the years?
Absolutely not.
It's the end market so a lot of
you email me and say I've been
doing a daily vlog called
"DailyVee" and a lot of music
has been given to DRock for us
and we use a lot of it and we're
getting hundreds of emails now
because they are getting a lot
of exposure from people that
are watching the YouTube show
and it's helping them so a lot
of people want their music on
the show and everybody writes
the same thing which is,
"This is great.
My stuff is great.
"Everybody tells it's great."
And the answer is
I think at some level the
market gets to decide.
Everybody wants to
think they're great.
I always think about the way
American Idol when it first came
out those people in that first
show of every season where they
really truly not the people just
trying to get on TV later but
those first two or three seasons
where you would just genuinely
see somebody who literally
thought they were great. Right?
Who literally thought they were
great and in that environment
judges got to
decide if they moved on.
I think what is so fascinating
about today's music marketplace
and the business marketplaces
with the internet being the true
middleman whether you Soundcloud
or blogs pick you up or you put
out YouTube stuff or Vimeo or
whatever you do I think what
separates the people
that make a living or not
is the paying customer.
That enough people decide you
are great that it allows you to
do it for a living.
- I actually think the ones that
do it for hobby versus living
it's quite simply 10,000 hours.
And you guys started
it was very different than
what it was four
or five years later and you
guys continue to get better.
- Do you think that Malcolm
Gladwell like put in the work,
do you really think
that really think that?
For example--
- Yes. I do.
- Do you think if I put in
10,000 hours of EDM skills that
I could be great at EDM.
'Cause I can tell
you right now I can't.
- Ok.
- I genuinely think
that talent has been
stripped out of the equation.
- As an artist or as a producer?
- Both because I can tell
you right now that is
just not in me.
- Authenticity has
to be part of it.
And that's not authentic to you.
- Well, that's right.
That's right.
But I do think the 10,000 hour
thing is very fascinating and I
do think and I talk about hustle
and hard work a lot. I just am
surprised that talent is
starting to get scripted
out of the equation.
To be a musician like you guys
are, you guys are talented and
that's a thing.
- I have to interject here.
- Please.
- I don't think that I, first of
all, I don't think that I'm up
to par with certain
artist that I look up to.
When you talk about Adele's
vocals I don't think
I was born a prodigy.
- But you don't need to be the
number one singer in
the world to have success.
- But I don't think I
was born with this--
- Do you think you have a better
voice than the average hundred
people out there?
- No, I don't.
- Oh, yes.
- The reason I say that
is because I think there's this
mentality today where
people think artists on this
unobtainable pedestal but if
you go back to the beginning of
human civilization everyone was
sitting in a circle banging on
some drums and
singing all together.
It wasn't a separate
outsider, entitled group.
- I think everybody can sing,
I just don't think everyone
wants to pay everybody
to hear them to sing.
- Today, I think it's different.
I think it's vision, it's your
voice, it's your songwriting,
it's how you curate
your music videos.
It's everything.
- The issue with your romantic
point of view right now is it's
not being executed in reality.
There are hundreds of millions
of people that want to do,
there's tens of millions of
Americans that want to do what
you are doing right now.
And more interestingly and you
guys know this, you're in the
scene it's much more what's
happening in entrepreneurship,
it's what's
happening in athletics.
There are plenty of people that
have put in lots and lots of
hours especially if they
come from affluence where their
parents have allowed them to
be able to go to every fucking
lesson 47,000 times.
Sometimes talent has to
be part of the equation.
- And hunger too though.
- Sure.
- Sometimes people
are given everything.
- Sure. The work ethic is
a big variable.
Alright before we start getting
really testy here let's go to
the second question.
(silence)
- Ooh, that's a good one.
- I'm going to jump into this.
(crosstalk)
You don't get this
question after the show?
So, I think that that's a great
question by Heather I think
rented land has a negative point
of view here right now in the
way that she asked the question.
So many people are scared that
they don't own their Facebook
page, they don't own their
Snapchat account what I don't
think people understand is
that's the ways it's always been
about everything always.
When he showed up on
television on good day,
Good Morning America or on
The Ed Sullivan show
you didn't own that.
You're more than welcome to be
able to go and build your own
app and things of that nature.
How we got connected with
Backstage you know I'm investor
in you guys where that world is
going is very fascinating to me
but I don't think it
should cripple one.
Do I think that if you can own
it and execute it there and have
everybody there like an email
list, like your own website,
like your own app, does
that have more upside?
For sure.
I think there's a chicken and
egg issue though which is if
nobody's there, why you go
on Snapchat and Facebook?
'Cause everybody's there.
And you want to siphon and I
love how people are like I'm
doing all the
stuff for Facebook.
No, no Facebook's doing
all the stuff for you.
They've curated hundreds of
millions of people into one
place that give you a chance
to be seen or heard so I think
there's a little
chicken and egg thing.
I do think as you gain more
traction and have more leverage
that you're able to take a
little more control of your
environment if you choose to but
I think both work and so to me
rented space is very
comfortable to me.
To me, anywhere where there's
attention is a viable place for
one to speak to the world and
achieve their story outwardly
and I would not be crippled
by doing either or both.
- Jake.
- I couldn't have
said that better.
- Damn. Yeah.
- I do that naturally that
wasn't 10,000 hours
of work, it was.
- For me, I'm like let me let
our manager talk about that.
- Alright, let's move it.
- [Voiceover] Erica says, "Talk
to us about the importance of
"knowing your fans and
owning your own platform!"
- So much importance.
I totally think you need to be
able to connect with the people
who are paying for your music,
paying to come see your live
shows, even not paying just
ripping offline and really
loving your music.
Those of the people who support
your entire career if you can't
connect with them either that's
online, face-to-face at shows
etc. then you have nothing.
- How much time are you guys
spending and it's okay if it's a
zero I'm just curious how much
time are you spending actually
engaging with
your fans on social?
Because for me
that feels scalable.
You can't be in Des Moines, Iowa
right now but if Susie says,
"I love your stuff,"
you can engage.
It was such a big thing for me
in my early days but I do think
that it's becoming out of fad.
I think people are spending
less time today than they did 36
months ago engaging with fans.
I think it's a little
better decline in Twitter.
I think if you look at all the
social networks besides Twitter
they're more push content out.
Instagram, Snapchat, YouTube you
push content out whereas Twitter
when it was in it's prime was a
little more back-and-forth so
I was curious, don't forget if
it doesn't come natural
to everybody.
You're doing other things but
where you guys right now with
literally like making a video
and being like, "Thanks, Sal,"
or replying to Karen in a Snap
or engaging with a comment in
Instagram and
actually replying to it?
Tell the truth because I'm going
to double check and call you out
if you bullshit me
here in my house.
- I would say not as
much as we used to.
What you're saying earlier
about how you spent 15 hours
responding to comments
about an event that happened.
When we first started off, Jake
was saying follow every fan.
Jake, you were
really, really encouraged us.
Yeah, exactly.
We used to, I remember being
at the airport waiting in line
responding to fans.
Being in the car, responding to
fans and after certain period of
time--
- You have to.
I felt it actually really
worked well for us as far as
building our social media fan
base but I felt like it stifled
my creativity.
- Interesting.
- And living, not really knowing
how to live in the real world--
- Yes.
- in a way I felt every moment
I had to wait or every moment
I didn't have to
talk to someone.
Every moment I was sitting
at a table I was on my phone.
Nowadays, I actually practiced
just giving myself an allotment
of time and I feel like our fan
base is really understanding of
that because we've been
pretty vocal of that.
- Interesting.
- I don't think they think they
take it personally that it takes
us five days to respond.
- That's your authentic place.
- Yeah.
I also feel like spiritually I'm
going one direction where I want
to spend less time online,--
- Yes.
- business-wise I understand
that it's so
important to engage.
- Of course.
- That's why we do
have people like Jake.
- What about you?
- I go through phases.
We just released
an EP a month ago.
I was online the entire week
pretty much just responding to
people consistently.
Kinda went downhill after there
and I probably spend a good
three hours every week just
responding to people every
Monday or every Friday I
just sit down and respond.
- And where?
What platforms?
- Twitter mainly.
That's the only one.
- Are you guys producing
content for Snapchat?
- No.
- You really, really need to.
(laughter)
- I just want to say as an
artist it is really important to
have a marketing firm, have
management, have friends,
have people to
help curate content.
What we do is we sit down, we
have a meeting once a week, hey,
look at all these pictures.
These are fun pictures we've
taken, this is what we did,
here's what we want to say about
it and have someone else kind
of do that work on that
and so it's not.
- I think I don't think that's
an artist statement, I think
it's great that you have
self-awareness to know what
works for you.
'Cause I think a certain artists
they should be doing a ton of
that because it what
comes natural to them.
A lot of my business friend
contemporaries are like, "You're
running all these businesses.
Why are you spending
four hours a day
engaging with fans?"
I'm like, "That's
my natural state.
"It's where I get my information
from. It's when I want to do."
But I don't think that's
what everybody should do.
I like listening to the
way you guys answered.
What I like is I just think you
guys are figuring yourselves out
and putting yourself in the best
position to succeed and I think
really that
ultimately is the main play.
I really do.
- I think fans crave an
experience, a story much more
and content much more than
they crave whether or not you're
responding to them.
- I disagree.
I would actually argue and you
can be right but I'm completely
and I have a lot of data to
support this believe that access
is the most valuable thing
an artist can now
bring to the table.
- I agree.
- Access meaning
that you're accessible?
- Like some sort of access.
- Like happy birthday to you.
- I think you can
touch a movement.
You do it with a lot of brands
if a brand doesn't respond to
questions within four hours--
- Sure.
- that's a problem.
But when you're an artist your
responsibility is
to create amazing art.
- I think that's for sure.
First of all, no good
marketing solves a shit product.
If you guys engage 24/7 with
everybody but your music sucked
shit, you would lose.
On the flip side,
I do think that people
really underestimate.
I can promise you right now your
top 5,000 fans would shit their
pants if you reply
to them on Snapchat.
- I don't even
know how to do that.
(crosstalk and laughter)
- I don't even
know, how do you reply?
- We're not going to do this
right now because we're still in
the middle of the show.
What I'm going to do right
now is even more interesting.
Guys this is my snap, can you
guys make a commitment to get
serious about Snap?
- Oh God, no.
- Please.
- I'm sorry, I can't.
- I'll try. I'll try.
See the thing is about Snapchat
the reason it's the one platform
that I do not use
because it's the one,--
- See you're not even listening.
- I don't understand.
- I'm listening to you.
- How do you do that and
listen at the same time?
- Easy.
- Your generation, man.
- No, no, no.
I think that it's behavior.
Right? It's the 10,000 hours.
You put in the
work, you can do it.
- You can multitask like
that for 10,000 hours.
- I think you
multi-task quite a bit.
- I do.
- Of course, it's
just what we do.
Let's move on.
- [Voiceover] Tom asks,
"How'd you girls get hooked
"up with Jake Udell?"
How big of an influence
has it had on your career?"
- High school.
- Yep.
I graduated with Jake Udell.
Jake was in my science,
what was it?
Which science class?
Was it biology?
All I know is I got a D.
Got a D.
(laughter)
And Jake you were
actually if you want to talk
about your music career.
You were pursuing
being an artist.
- I was an awful rapper.
Like the worst.
DJ Khaled and DJ Drama
actually posted my mix tape.
- Why didn't you just
put in the 10,000 hours?
- I did. I did.
- And become--
- So here's the thing
I gave up on my
10,000 hours as a musician--
- Because you
didn't have the talent.
- Okay, I'll admit that.
- Jake has this swag.
- See here's the thing, I made
a pivot and said okay--
- Because you were smart.
Because not everybody
can do anything
if they put in 10,000 hours.
- I actually believe, I believe
that if you put in the 10,000
hours it can happen.
I'm not saying you can be
performing at the Grammys but
you can it's possible
to have a hit record.
I believe that can happen.
- Okay. Anything can happen.
But it doesn't
consistently happen.
To me that's the
point which is like--
- That's what's so fascinating
about what Malcolm said though.
Malcolm said he couldn't find
people that have put in the
10,000 hours that
hadn't made it.
Of course 'cause their stores
weren't known because he was
trying to find them and
he couldn't find them.
- How many hours did
you put into rapping?
- Oh my gosh.
- Exactly.
- Not 10,000 though,
not even close.
- But that's impossible.
If you suck shit at something
and you put 10,000 hours you're
not going to become
one of the greats in it.
- Right.
- I was a better marketer.
- There's enormous amounts of
kids, every single kid that
tried become a professional
athlete that didn't become a
professional athlete which is
almost everybody put in all the
hours from first grade to
senior year and didn't make it.
- 10,000 though? That's the
thing when you look at that--
- I don't know the math
on what 10,000 hours is.
- Did I spent 10,000 hours for
my rap career or was I 10,000
hours in the studio?
I was definitely not 10,000
hours in the studio trying to be
the best rapper.
- I love Malcolm.
Nobody can convince me.
If that was true then we should
tell every six-year-old right
now to spend every minute of
your time on the number one
thing that you want to be and
you will become that and
that is absolute bullshit.
- I think that's
absolutely true.
- So you think if I take a first
grader right now and say you're
going to become a
world-class surfer--
- If he wants to be.
- if he or she wants to be than
you'll think they'll become a
world-class surfer?
- That's so tough.
I think they'll find
their career in surfing.
I think that's a logical great
decision that six-year-old.
- And you're saying that because
you found your career in the
music industry whether or not
you were trying manage or not.
- The thing is the guy before,
the first question
he was asking about--
- Nobody wants to be a manager
when they want to be a star.
- I do.
- No, now.
- Oh yeah.
- When you were 11--
- I believed in them more than
I believed in myself so that was
the turning point.
- Because they had talent.
- Yeah. They're good.
- I think that that's the point.
I really mean that because you
have to understand where I'm
coming from and where my energy
is coming from. Right now we are
looking to the greatest era
of fake entrepreneurs ever.
Every single person that is
under 25 is coming out of school
and they're like,
"I'm an app founder."
I'm sure you talk to these
people everybody's a fucking
entrepreneur and they just think
because they've said it and
they're gonna put in the time
and effort that automatically
makes them a successful
entrepreneur and that's the key.
Which is you can be anything.
Do I believe if I put in 10,000
hours into surfing that
I'd be a good surfer?
I sure do.
Do I think I could
win the competitions
they have in Hawaii?
No, I do not.
I think there is a secondary
thing that has to happen.
Look at the NBA.
You mentioned Adele, what
about the 12th man on the Heat.
Right?
He's one of the best 300
basketball players in the world
but and he's made it but what
about a person right after that
the person in the D-League
that's making tens of
thousands of dollars?
That guy is literally one of 500
best basketball players in
the world but hasn't won,
hasn't made it by the
Malcolm categorization.
And then you have just millions
of people, there's millions of
people that are trying to make
EDM and hip hop music right this
second and so many of them
can't succeed in the marketplace
'cause the talent is a variable.
I really do believe that.
I just don't see how one
doesn't understand that.
There's so many
people that want it.
There are so many people that
put in those hours in so many
things and especially in music
and sports which are very high
glossy, exciting things to be in
society like I don't know.
I'm fascinated by the talent
conversation because I think it
is a dangerous conversation
because I was picking
and prodding.
The reason I'm in a good mood
as you're talking a lot more now
about self-awareness.
I think a lot of kids right
now are getting eighth place
trophies and they think they are
good enough and then the world
hits them in the face and that's
what we have so much depression
and other things that people
don't everybody was a "rah-rah."
Everybody wants you can do it.
Nobody understands that when
they don't do it what happens
that kid's psyche.
- Mhmmm.
- I think part of being a
successful young person is you
get the opportunity
to make those pivots.
You get the opportunity to say,
"Okay I'm in eighth place maybe
"I should become a coach.
"Maybe I should change
my career progression."
- When you're getting the
direction that you can still do
it, you can still do it when so
few can then you start getting
into a place where we're selling
a bill of goods to the youth
that isn't true and you start
dealing with what I think
the mental health issues that
are not being talked about
where everybody all of a sudden
after 50 years of prosperity
in America thinks that they're
going to become Adele and LeBron
and they don't and
then they're baffled.
- Do you think that when you
talk about the 10,000 hour rule
that the people that are making
it, do you think part of that is
the equation is
perseverance though?
You should have heard the songs
we wrote back in a day and we
still write to this day and I
could have checked out and said,
"Hey, I just don't have talent."
- I don't think there is a
single person that's successful
that didn't put
in the hard work.
Which is the reverse
of the conversation.
I just don't think that if you
put in the hard work you can
necessarily be successful.
There's nobody that's achieved
what you've achieved or what
I've achieved that got
there by accident and
didn't put in the work.
- How many entrepreneurs or
talented people have you met
that have put in the level of
work that you've put in in to
what you do to create all of
this amazing office by the way
that haven't made it
in a significant level?
I don't know any.
- First of all, nobody works 18
hours a day like I do but
(laughter)
the punchline is I know a lot of
kids that have been hustling for
the last six or seven years
trying to build and are on the
third business and
they're never going to make it.
A lot.
Because they're schlemiels.
- They're what?
- Schlemiels.
They don't have it.
- That's a Russian word?
- It's probably a Yiddish word
if I had really get to
the core of it.
They don't have the skill to be
a business person that can make
a business successful. The end.
There the kids on "American
Idol" who literally come,
think they're Adele sing
and we all laughed.
- The fact that they're on their
third business a lot of them
being schlemiels is that
they're kinda BS, they're not--
- Let's go into a
different place.
Are you telling me that
talent has no part of the
equation of success?
- Oh huge.
- Well that's
what you're saying.
- Huge.
- I just want you to
know by definition.
I want you watch this--
- To achieve talent.
I truly believe that and there
have been some people in our
experience that have come around
that we maybe met
three, four years ago.
- I understand.
I think people can break
through and get better.
Do you think everybody can?
Do you think the majority can?
- No.
- But I think everybody
has a unique talent though.
It might not be music or
sports but you have to find it.
Part of being a successful
20-something is understanding
how to maneuver in times of
change and understand that you
have to sometimes
pivot to be successful.
- And how many of
those 20-year-old are
gonna find success?
- As many that want to.
- That's not true.
- As many who are studying the
same principles and same values
that you have.
- Last question before
I get really burning.
I feel like I'm going to burn
this table now but I love it.
I love it because I love it
because I love, first of all, it's
so funny because on the most
optimistic person I know and
I feel like I'm
Debbie Downer here.
I do think what's scaring me and
why I'm talking about it is
I think the pendulum swinging
a little bit too much to
"Anybody can make it.
Everybody can make it.
"Just put in the work."
I believe in that but I think
that maximizes what you have.
I think the work will maximize
what you have I just don't think
everybody has it.
Especially when
you get into art.
When you get into music and
sports and things of that nature
I think that is a tough challenge.
Last question.
- [Voiceover] Chris asks,
"How do you girls stay so
"grounded in a fake world?"
- In a fake world?
- Why does the
world got to be fake?
- The people I surround
myself with aren't fake.
- Yeah, same.
- And who says you
guys are grounded?
(laughter)
- Exactly.
- We might be batshit crazy,
you just don't know.
If I were to answer that
question I was also say family.
We are family for each other
obviously we're sisters and we're
very close with our family and
nothing happens that doesn't
slide by our our dad or our mom
and they keep us in check and we
keep each other in check.
- And also not feeling entitled.
I think that's something we
really surrounded by especially
in the dance music realm
there so many DJs who have this
entitled aura and you could
see it online and in person.
- There's so much subtext
what you're saying right now.
- There's like this hierarchy of
what kind of value bring and why
that's more valuable than other
careers or other realms in art.
I think that's what, even the
first question when you're
saying what made you pop off.
- Yeah.
- I've actually never
felt like we popped off.
I never really felt
that we made it.
I think the day I really feel
Krewella made it is when I'm
going to lose that hunger and
I think we have to constantly
remind ourselves to understand
our value and our worth and to
acknowledge our achievements
as artist but not to let that
hinder us from having that
hunger to work every day, to go
to the studio every day, to say
yes to opportunities because the
second you start
saying, "Oh no, I'm good."
- "We made it."
- Exactly.
- Or "I'm too good."
- Yeah.
- What do you think?
- For them?
- Or about the game?
Where do you think, while
I've got you for another second,
where is the current state
of EDM in your guy's opinion?
Obviously it was a that space,
I don't know, eight years ago,
nine years ago most people
didn't know about. I still think
there's a lot of people who
are watching who are 40,
50-year-old marketing dudes that
have no idea what this space is
and they're going to Google it.
But obviously when you start
talking to a 35 and under demo in
America and obviously in Europe
and other places it's been huge,
everybody at this point already
knows that it's so
interesting to watch.
It is really to me the thing
that is most followed hip hop as
a new genre that
didn't really exist before.
I'm curious for you guys who
are much closer to it,
where is it in it's lifecycle?
Just starting, hitting
an interesting time?
It's become dramatically more
mainstream than it was
five, six years ago.
What is your
point of view on it?
- I think it has plateaued.
I think it's hit the climax--
- Okay.
- I don't think it's
going anywhere, anytime soon.
It just branched off in so
many different directions.
There's so many
different sub-genres.
There's new artist coming
through every day.
Guys likes Skrillex and
Diplo are doing a great job of
cosigning younger talent,
bringing them up through the
system and there's the
difference between it now and
what it was 15 years ago was how
much corporate backing it gets.
You see with the brands
you work with all the time
and how badly they want to be
involved with these entities and
the biggest throwers of
festivals in the world, these
biggest entertainment companies
in the world have put so much
money into making sure that
it's going to stay where it is.
Keep going with it.
- Ladies?
- It's hard for me to comment
on this because I do feel like
we've never quite
belonged in the EDM world--
- Okay.
- and so it's hard for me to
look at us as even still a part
of it even though I know it's
kinda one foot in the door,
one out for us.
- Okay.
- We've always tried to maintain
our own lane while still, again,
keeping one foot
in the EDM world.
- I understand.
- I think that that's probably a
good thing for us because like
Jake said, I agree, I think it
has plateaued and we have this
amazing opportunity to take
ourselves on a completely
different lane and
pave our own way.
- Do our own thing.
- Yeah, it's cool.
- I just think a lot of what
were talking about when you're
talking about depression with a
lot of young entrepreneurs--
- Yes.
- maybe feeling let down that
they can't really achieve the
success that they been hyped up
to achieve, what do you think our
society being a more and more
fame obsessed society has to do
with that especially
with social media?
- Yeah, I think the whole 15
minutes of fame has become
everybody is
famous to 15 people.
You got an entire generation of
young teens right now that take
45 minutes and take a selfie
'cause they want to get the
lighting right and post on
Instagram if it doesn't get
enough likes they
take it down right away.
Peer pressure, I've never
been more obsessed with this.
I have a seven and a
four-year-old, instilling
self-esteem in to them is
everything because they're going
to need it really, really big.
- Yeah.
- Because the market's gonna
push back on every
one of their flaws.
Yeah, I think we're living
through a really, really
interesting time.
I really do.
I think there a lot of
things happening at once.
This is not a very simple issue
where it's like social media.
I think parents, I'm 40, parents
of my generation that grew up
during great times, you know
we're not our parents or our
grandparents, great-grandparents
generation where they fought
wars and the Depression
and things of that nature.
We've had so much prosperity
that I think if you look at
every empire that when things
are good for too long
people become soft.
And I think that's
what's happening.
I think we're soft.
And I think, you know,
coming from an immigrant
DNA, like you guys, it's easier
for me to see it.
I just think we're soft and
I think that and I think that
I don't want to add to it.
As a very positive optimistic
rah-rah, crush it, anybody can
do it guy I want to also at
least have the other part of the
equation which is of course hard
work, of course talent and of
course look there's so much
going on in the world right now.
I think we're all sensitive to
a lot of different things
that are happening.
You never know when
prosperity can end.
It ends in a blink.
I'm thankful for
the way that it is.
I do not think kids being stuck
in their cell phones all day
is a bad thing.
I don't think
that's a ruining them.
I think technology is eating the
world and I think it's going to
be more of that.
I think that when you guys first
started doing shows compared to
now if you think about phone
usage at your shows when you
guys are standing there, I'm
curious what you think about
what's going on down there
because that's just their norm.
- Mhmmm.
- I love when people think, did
you guys see that picture of the
90-year-old woman that was in
the crowd when the Pope came and
everybody took a photo she
didn't and everybody made a big
deal about that? You did.
Did you see this?
- Yeah.
- You did you see it?
You see it?
So it's a photo like six months
ago when the Pope came to the US
I think that everybody made
a big deal about which is
everybody taking a photo of it
she just standing, she's like 90
and she just standing there and
everybody's like she's a hero
and literally I take
a reverse view on it.
I feel bad for her because she's
old and she probably already
forgot about that moment where
as everybody else recorded it.
I know it's a funny--
- That's age discrimination.
- Of course it's
age discrimination.
I'm trying to make a zing
joke, I'm sure she remembers it.
I have no idea who she is but
I think that change is tough.
In the same way that, staying to
music, both hip hop and EDM, one
foot in, one foot out both those
genres had nothing but haters in
the beginning saying,
"That's not real music."
- Mhmmm.
- And I just don't like when
people impose their thoughts.
Just 'cause kids are
communicating this way doesn't
mean that
millennials are introverted.
I love when all my old friends
and when I said old I mean
35-year-olds say these kids
can't hold a real conversation
because their having them here.
Meanwhile these same kids spoke
to the same six people their
entire childhood because
they didn't have the outlet to
different people,
different things.
These kids are
much more worldly.
They know a lot more and so
I don't think anything is bad.
I'm pretty much and
optimist that way.
But I am worried about
depression because I do think
way more scary to me than living
a public life and fame obsession
is parents telling their kids
things that aren't realistic.
I do think that we have to train
our generation to deal with
adversity and I don't think
getting an eighth trophy, I do
not if you come in fucking last
place that your team should be
cheering and
celebrating and given trophies.
They should be looked at
like, "You guys
suck shit. You lost."
- Don't you think that this--
- I do believe that's healthy.
- But the advice to the
entrepreneur to push through--
- These guys are
going out of business.
Do you understand
what's going to happen?
99% of these--
- So they move on
to the next one.
- It's not an
opportunity to get better?
- Of course it is.
- Keep going.
People out there, keep going.
- Of course, keep going but if
you are not self-aware, if you
kept rapping, my man,
you would not be as happy
as you are today.
- Agreed.
- So now go that tell them
to keep going
when they're delusional.
- You'll figure it out.
- That was the moment.
That's the bottom line.
You understand?
You guys keep
going, keep evolving--
- Yes.
- but blindly going that I'm
going to be Eminem
isn't gonna work.
- But if you don't do that,
you'll never figure it out.
If I hadn't put all the time and
energy into that I wouldn't have
understood how to
market recording artist.
- That's a very different thing
then keep evolving and being
self-aware and understanding
your strengths and weaknesses to
create the next opportunity
versus what people normally hear
when you hear keep going which
is if I just keep putting in
more hours eventually
I'm gonna put out a song.
(inaudible)
You didn't keep
putting out songs--
- I did until something else
but if I hadn't kept going, if I
would've stopped those thousands
and thousands of times
people told me I couldn't do it.
- But please understand in this
conversation when you look back
at it you adjusted to a different
opportunity on those learnings.
That's not what people hear--
- That's keep going though.
- by your definition but I'm
telling you right now that's
what would people hear.
When people hear keep going they
think they're going to break
through on the thing, do you
know that everybody wants to be
a famous singer, a famous
athlete and a famous actor and
if that person keeps acting
instead of becoming a director
which is maybe the skill set
they have they're gonna lose.
- I think what you're saying
keep going but stay focused but
be open to reinventing
yourself all along the way.
- Be self-aware.
It's my favorite part of this.
It's what I jumped on earlier.
If you actually know yourself
you can win so much more.
Just this blind faith that
everybody's entitled to this
level of success is ludicrous.
Because most people don't want
to work hard enough, most people
don't have enough talent and the
math has proven that
that's not the case.
The bottom of the 1%, the 1%
earners in America, the top 1%
earners, the bottom of
that make $400,000 a year.
If you go talk every 15 to
22-year-old, they don't even
conceive anything being
short of a millionaire,
of making $1 million a year.
But the data shows only 1%
in our US society
make $400,000 or
more and that makes
them one of the top 1%.
We have not had the proper
conversation for every one of
you guys, there are 50,000
groups that didn't make it and
it wasn't because they
gave up one year too early.
They just weren't
talented enough.
That's what I believe.
Question of the day.
- He drops the mic.
- You guys get to ask a question
of the day which is cool.
I'm curious to see
where you guys go with it.
You get to ask the
Vayner Nation any question.
There will be hundreds of
answers on YouTube and
Facebook. Go.
- Oh, we get to ask it?
- Yes. You.
- Oh my god, 'cause I
feel like I kinda asked you.
Sorry.
- No, not me.
You're asking the masses,
everybody that just
watched this right now.
- Can I get a minute
to think about it?
- Yes.
- Something that I wanted to
ask you but I guess I can ask
everyone else 'cause a lot of
them are the same boat as you
as a parent how would
you raise your
children with or without
social media?
- Interesting.
- Or technology?
- That would be interesting.
- Or what?
- Or with it and if they kept,
if you decided for them to have
social media in their life if
they decided not to ban social
media from the household what
would your child
rearing be like?
- Technology in general.
I mean you see one
year olds on an iPad.
- And you see that as bad?
- I don't know,
I'm not a parent.
- I understand
but you're a human.
- I don't like it.
It disgusts me.
When I see I think too many
airplane or airport restaurants
where I've seen a parent on
their iPhone and a baby with an
iPad and the toddler with
playing another game and a
toddler playing another game.
- Now what if showed you the
world 18 years from now and the
entire ecosystem of relevance
and being able to even survive
it is predicated on technology
because that's the
evolution of man.
- Maybe this is my
romantic point of view,
like you said before--
- Oh it.
- What's the deal
with being relevant?
Why is everyone so obsessed
with saying, "Oh, you're not
"relevant any more," or "Oh,
you're trying to be relevant."
Everyone is so
obsessed with relevance.
- Relevant is contextual.
- Culturally relevant.
- Relevant is you can't
even communicate to your
grandchildren because they're
only willing to text you and you
miss you granddaughter.
That's why grandma--
- It's important to adapt but
I think it's important to adapt
but at the same time
I think that, at least what
I've seen from my generation
younger is this
obsession with being relevant.
It's all based on pop culture as
if you don't know what's going
on or if you're not
tweeting about what's going on.
- That's never changed.
That's never changed.
It used to be confined to a
high school because
you wanted to be popular.
- I like living under a rock.
- You're more than welcome.
You're more than welcome.
I think that you guys
should shut it down right now.
No more albums,
live under a rock.
- I think were losing value--
- Of course there's
always a trade-off.
- I don't want my value
to be based off what
I know in pop culture.
What basketball team is winning.
- You have to
understand though--
- Who performed at
what award show.
- But you don't have to
and many people don't.
You also understand that same
technology is why you're even
sitting here right now.
The information that is built
on top of the internet itself is
the only reason, maybe not the
only reason, you might have been
lucky in an old-school music
environment and had somebody in
LA saying, "No, no, you two
girls are going to make it."
But there's
always pros and cons.
- I get that.
That's why I am extremely
conflicted artist because the
very system that we're working
within, it's also I see myself
going opposite direction
spiritually like I said before.
- I think that's cool.
I think you're in full control
and I think much like anything
even though we may disagree in
certain things in this episode
when people watch
that's what's awesome.
First of all, it's
going to play out.
I think humans have a good
track record of sticking around.
We been around for a long time,
we've evolved you know what you
would get a real kick out of?
Go read the articles written
about the intervention of the
television, the invention of the
phone, the invention of video
games all of it ruined us.
- Yeah.
- I'm ruined because I played
Zelda and Mike Tyson's Punchout.
Just so you know.
- We weren't allowed to
play video games growing up.
- Respect. Alright,
we're out of here.
You keep asking question,
we'll keep debating them.